la motion eye pet soit la mode est là le
raf c'est plus qu'un style de midi c'est
aussi une façon de commenter l'actualité
les noms des champions à gatineau chaque
mois le rappeur du trac compose une
chanson inspirée d'événements récents
il en est à sa 25e faux souvenirs
l'actualité si je pense les gens ont les
mêmes références que moi ces frais dans
la mémoire des gens et puis en même
temps c'est ça ça me fasse à travailler
sur des références pop du moment
il met pas le seul à s'adonner à cet
exercice l'américaine colmar duff obtenu
près de 600000 visionnement anti-jo avec
son rap up 2020 depuis ses débuts que
rap rime avec actualité depuis les ailes
la naissance du rap les rabats sont à la
base des reporters de notre société je
trouve que ce sont les et les porte voix
en fait de réalité qu'on n'entend pas de
voix qu'on entend peu au delà des
clichés du gangsta rap c'est un style
qui commente le quotidien et dénoncent
les travers de notre société comme dans
la chanson tout recommencer ce collectif
odst est pas accès aux ressources de
l'absence de public en première page une
forte fumée guyane en fait un buzz pour
la cause sahraouie ce qui compte c'est
d'être comprise
en fait pour moi c'est ça le le défi
principal quand j'écris une chanson
c'est que le message passe et que et que
les gens comprennent ce que je veux dire
le rap c'est une musique qui qui qui est
très vrai qui doit ressembler à
l'artiste qui doit aussi refléter la
réalité c'est les bases en plus du hip
hop c'est vraiment journalisme en fait
signe des temps les deux grandes revues
terry visite fin d'année on confie à des
rappeurs la mission de résidus levèrent
music you bye bye
cityzen tv
il sera mis à infoman pour l'eonia
mississauga il ya des pénuries même
beaucoup s'est passé ni tragédie et
beaucoup de choses vont toucher tout le
monde et mon but c'était vraiment d'être
dans les faits elle prépare son nouvel
album teinté des événements des derniers
mois tout comme le travail des tracts
qui s'alimentent de notre quotidien bon
ou mauvais sens qui l'on pratique pour
moi c'est comme jongler avec un ballon
de 5 mp un premier album s à aller sur
le terrain
ra d'actualité pour radio canada hier
j'ai chaussé mes plus beaux avidan a
rejeté interviews et pas même un avis
qui décide s'il est bien etc sont
repartis radio-canada gatineau